what would actually happen if you
ran out of electrolytes now if you ran
out completely you would die
but if you ran out just a little bit all
sorts of things would happen but the
main big thing that will happen is
you'll lose electrical power
of your nerves your muscles
and your cells i have a really short
little demo
to tell you exactly what i mean all
right we're going to do an experiment a
demonstration we have a light source
we have a power source it's plugged into
the wall over here you can see the cords
and we have an incomplete circuit okay
electrical circuit we cut the wire
and we put the wire into
distilled water distilled water is water
without minerals and without
electrolytes electrolytes are
electrically charged
minerals okay so we have no
conductivity here you can see there
there's no light so we're going to take
some electrolytes here
take a scoop of electrolytes
and we'll pour it in
to this distilled water
and let's see what happens
okay now we're gonna mix it with the
water to
make sure it's
dissolving and look what's happening we
have a
complete circuit now
so one of the main purposes of
electrolytes in the body is to power the
nervous system which is the electrical
system the body which powers the muscles
and all the different organs all right
so now that you know generally what
electrolytes are let's talk about how
you would create a deficiency
well one way is when you start doing
fasting especially if you do prolong
fasting and you only drink water without
electrolytes you see our bodies don't
store electrolytes for a long period of
time i'm talking about potassium
magnesium sodium chlorides or calcium
okay they don't store these minerals so
if you're drinking water first of all
you're diluting these minerals when
you're fasting and then you're not
eating you're gonna run out of
electrolytes and a lot of people are
already running on a low tank of
electrolytes and so when they start
fasting they might not feel good they
might feel dizzy they get fatigued keto
flu other symptoms and they might even
pass out very important to take
electrolytes when you do fasting all
right number two if you start the
ketogenic diet you may run out of
electrolytes why because you're
switching to
ketones or fat fuel you're no longer
running on glucose and what happens is
your body dumps a lot of these stored
glucose so store glucose as glycogen is
just a bunch of glucose molecules strung
together with a lot of water because for
every one gram of glucose that's stored
you have three grams of water so
glycogen is a fluid-filled sugary
substance that's stored in your liver
and stored in your muscles it's not
stored in the brain it's in the liver
and the muscles and other organs as well
so what happens when you stop eating
sugar is you start dumping
all this glycogen as well as fluid an
average person could lose like 13 pounds
of extra fluid and with the fluid comes
electrolyte so you're going to lose a
lot of electrolytes like even potassium
so this is why i recommend electrolytes
with keto and fasting but on the flip
side when you consume a high carb diet
especially if there's sugar and refined
carbs involved in that high carb diet
you also become deficient electrolytes
because
to store
that sugar as glycogen you also need
potassium so when you lose glycogen when
you do keto you lose potassium and then
when you consume a lot of high
carbohydrates you lose potassium because
it's locked up and stored in the
glycogen which is not always readily
available to you
quick story my wife and i when we got
married like 31 years ago
we went to this
italian restaurant and we had
massive amounts of pasta
pizza
bread
desserts
wine
more desserts more bread more pasta so
we're driving home and i'm not feeling
too good okay i try to go to bed
and
my pulse rate is just like bam bam bam
bam just like way way too high i didn't
know back then what it was but
reflecting back it was a major potassium
deficiency because to store all that
sugar
my body was sucking potassium out of the
blood and pushing into that glycogen and
so the pulse rate went up
and that's why
number four increase pulse rate when you
run out of electrolytes
now also when you sweat vomit have
diarrhea
if you're on diuretics other medications
all of these can create an electrolyte
deficiency all right the next question
is what symptoms occur when you start
running out of electrolytes
arrhythmias why
because electrolytes power muscle not
just
your muscles like the skeletal muscles
but your cardiac muscles and so you may
not uh initially just feel arrhythmias
you might just feel like a heart
palpitation that could be an electrolyte
deficiency right number two fatigue why
because electrolytes power the body they
give the body
energy and the two minerals sodium
potassium work as a major pump to
generate a tremendous amount of energy
in all the cells to make everything work
and without those two electrolytes
things are going to be very very low
electrically that's the term keto
fatigue when you start keto because a
lot of people don't do electrolytes or
you might experience muscle weakness
that's usually a sodium deficiency a
person's not consuming enough
salts okay three
dizziness and dehydration you just don't
have the fluid to run the body and if we
don't have that we get dizzy
because we're dehydrated all right
number four i already talked about that
five muscle twitches spasm and cramps
so many people when they're sleeping get
these cramps and they don't know what it
is
it's an electrolyte problem right number
six constipation
well your colon is
smooth muscle so again it's just another
muscle that can be affected by
electrolytes
seven
headache and brain swelling now this
relates to a sodium deficiency many
times it could relate to other things
but
let's say for example you decided to
exercise and drink a lot of water and
sweat and not put the electrolytes back
in and you kept drinking more and more
water you can end up with a severe
sodium deficiency that's called
hyponatremia
where the brain actually starts swelling
so it's important that we're not
hydrated just with water we're hydrated
with electrolytes and water
number eight you can go into shock
number nine feel nauseated you know get
the keto flu
10 a loss of blood clotting factors and
that's specifically calcium so you can
see there's a lot of things that can
happen when you run out of electrolytes
probably the most important electrolyte
is potassium because you need it in such
large amounts if you haven't seen my
video on potassium i put it up right
here check it out